vean a estos levantadores de pesas el
que está a la derecha levanta las pesas
más rápido pero ambos están haciendo la
misma cantidad de trabajo y puedo decir
esto porque trabajo es la cantidad de
energía transferida o poniéndolo de
manera más simple trabajo es igual a la
energía que entregas o que quitas
ambos levantadores de pesas tienen la
misma cantidad de peso o energía
potencial gravitatoria ambos la elevan 2
metros y la masa es de 100 kilogramos
ponemos esto en la fórmula de energía
potencial gravitatoria y encontramos que
el trabajo realizado por cada levantador
de pesas es en 1960 jules sin embargo el
levantador de la derecha lo hace más
rápido así que debe haber una forma de
distinguir lo que está haciendo este de
lo que está haciendo el levantador de
pesas que va más lento y podemos hablar
de esta diferencia en física como
potencia la potencia mide la proporción
en la cual alguien como estos
levantadores de pesas o algo como un
motor de automóvil realiza trabajo en
específico la potencia se define como el
trabajo realizado entre el tiempo que
nos llevó a realizar ese trabajo ya
vimos que ambos levantadores de pesas
realiza en 1960 jules de trabajo al
levantador de pesas
la derecha le toma un segundo levantar
la pesa y al de la izquierda le toma 3
segundos
si incluimos estos tiempos en la
definición de potencia y veremos que la
salida de potencia de levantador de
pesas de la derecha es de 1960 jules por
segundo y la potencia de salida del
levantador de pesas de la izquierda es
solamente de 653 jules por segundo a un
joule por segundo se le llama watts en
honor al ingeniero escocés james watt y
watts se abrevia usando una doble un
mayúscula veamos otro ejemplo digamos
que tenemos un auto que tiene una masa
de 1000 kilogramos está en estado de
reposo y le toma 2 segundos a alcanzar
los 5 metros por segundo podemos
encontrar la potencia de salida del
motor al tomar el trabajo realizado en
el auto y dividirlo entre el tiempo que
le tomó realizar este trabajo para
encontrar el trabajo hecho en el auto
necesitamos encontrar cuál fue la
cantidad de energía que se le dio al
auto en este
al auto se le dio energía cinética y
tardó 2 segundos en tomar esta energía
cinética si ponemos los valores de la
masa y la rapidez del motor y el tiempo
que le llevó a realizar este trabajo
veremos que tiene una potencia de salida
de 6 mil 250 watts aunque aquí debemos
aclarar que hemos calculado la potencia
promedio porque estamos viendo el
trabajo total realizado entre un
intervalo de tiempo si tomara los
intervalos de tiempo que fueran cada vez
más pequeños nos acercaríamos cada vez
más a la potencia de salida en un
momento dado y si hiciéramos nuestro
intervalo de tiempo infinitesimal
encontraríamos la potencia de salida en
ese momento particular del tiempo y a
esto le llamamos potencia instantánea
típicamente al trabajar con
infinitesimales requiere que usemos
cálculo pero hay maneras de encontrar la
potencia instantánea sin tener que usar
cálculo
por ejemplo imaginemos que tenemos una
auto cuya potencia instantánea es de 6
mil 250 watts en cualquier momento del
tiempo dado ya que la potencia
instantánea nunca cambia la potencia
promedio va a igualar a la potencia
instantánea que va a ser igual a 6 mil
250 watts en otras palabras la potencia
promedio en cualquier intervalo de
tiempo va a igualar a la potencia
instantánea en cualquier momento
lo que quiere decir que el trabajo entre
el tiempo nos va a dar tanto la potencia
instantánea como la potencia promedio
ahora imaginemos que no tenemos tanta
suerte y la potencia instantánea está
cambiando en el tiempo mientras se mueve
este auto ahora como encontraríamos la
potencia instantánea sabemos que la
potencia es el trabajo entre el tiempo
así que lo que podemos intentar es usar
la fórmula para el trabajo qué es
efe por de por coseno de teta y esto
dividirlo entre el tiempo y algo que
quizá noten es que ahora tenemos la
distancia dividida entre el tiempo así
que vamos a aislar la distancia entre el
tiempo la distancia entre el tiempo es
la rapidez así que puedo reemplazar la
de entre por esta vez y si usamos la
rapidez instantánea de este auto en
cierto momento del tiempo encontraremos
la potencia instantánea de salida por la
fuerza de este auto en ese instante
particular del tiempo así que para
encontrar la potencia instantánea de
salida
por una fuerza usamos la fuerza en el
objeto durante cierto momento del tiempo
lo multiplicamos por la rapidez del
objeto durante ese mismo instante de
tiempo y lo multiplicamos por con seno
de teta pero aquí hay que tener cuidado
de está no es cualquier ángulo teta es
el ángulo que se forma entre la fuerza
en el objeto y la velocidad de ese
objeto pero en muchos casos la fuerza
tiene la misma dirección que la
velocidad del objeto lo que significa
que el ángulo entre la fuerza y la
velocidad es de 0 y ya que el coseno de
0 es igual a 1 no necesitaríamos el
coseno de teta en esta fórmula y
encontraríamos que la potencia
instantánea es simplemente igual a la
fuerza del objeto por su rapidez
entonces qué significa la potencia la
potencia es la proporción en la que se
realiza un trabajo y que significa la
potencia promedio la potencia promedio
es el trabajo realizado dividido
entre el intervalo de tiempo que nos
llevó a realizar ese trabajo que
significa la potencia instantánea la
potencia instantánea es la potencia de
salida realizada por una fuerza en un
momento particular en el tiempo